hey i love it when these wacky right
wingers turn on each other and donald
trump is now furious with kellyanne
conway his longtime advisor
kellyanne conway has now made a number
of statements which have infuriated
donald trump there's a politico article
about this former president donald trump
is denying a key anecdote from kellyanne
conway's book
saying he would have banished kellyanne
from his inner circle if she had ever
told him he lost the 2020 presidential
election so what's that issue here
is that kellyanne conway has now uh
kellyanne conway wrote
i had already said publicly what i'd
said privately to george his daily daily
oh this actually isn't the right thing
sorry where where is this here
um
it might the quote might actually not be
in this article kellyanne conway writes
in her book among other things that she
was one of the first people to tell
trump you lost you just you lost and
that's it you lost the election
and trump is now saying that that's not
true trump posted on his platform truth
social truth essential quote kellyanne
conway never told me that she thought we
lost the election
if she had i wouldn't have dealt with
her any longer she would have been wrong
could go back to her crazy husband
kellyanne conway's husband is anti-trump
republican george conway
back to the quote
writing books can make people say some
very strange things i wonder why got 12
million more votes than we did the first
time the most votes by far of any
sitting president the election was
rigged they used covid to cheat and
steal
and the evidence is massive and
indisputable
c
20 a 2 000 mules which of course is the
completely bogus and widely debunked
dinesh d'souza i can't even call it a
documentary because it doesn't document
anything real let's call it a
compilation of audio-visual elements
he's now promoting 2000 mules as
evidence so there's a few different
things going on here first of all it's
great when they fight amongst themselves
it weakens them generally speaking we
should encourage it that's number one
number two
when you lose even kellyanne conway you
have to start considering that this
might be the end of the grift to some
degree
but at this point trump won't let go of
this until he dies he it's just and we
don't know how long he's going to live
but he is clearly not going to let go of
this false claim that he actually won
and that no one around him was really
saying that you lost
he is going to stick with this until he
dies
he had the opportunity as i've said
before
to come out of the pandemic
easily be re-elected okay
all he had to do was say folks
covet is real
covet is scary
and we as americans
are going to come together
we're going to be patriotic we're going
to have trump masks we're going to have
american flag and mega masks i'm going
to be wearing them we should all wear
them we're going to deal with this
better than anybody we've got the best
doctors and we've got the best
university you know but just
right take that approach
and we need to give
our medical community time
to develop the treatments and vaccines
that they are going to develop
let's do it let's do it together that's
all trump had to do
the left would have done it
the right would have gone with it if
their cult leader said it
instead he was divisive
he would uh blatantly um shun and ignore
public health precautions
he almost ended up dead i mean look at
how seriously sick with covet he ended
up being he would talk about injecting
bleach
he would attack dr fauci
he would um
talk about china you know on and on and
on
he could have easily been reelected if
he just took it even slightly seriously
and said i am going to be the best on
covid not 15 cases will soon be zero not
ignore everything not we need our
freedom or any of this stuff
just follow the protocols we're going to
get through this and he couldn't do it
it's sort of like when he was given the
softballs of denouncing qanon or
denouncing white supremacy and nazis and
instead blames both sides or says he
doesn't know about it or doubles down or
whatever the case may be this guy was
given
these these were just teed up for him to
knock out of the park and he couldn't do
it and now the situation he's in is he
is going to take to his grave the lie
that he actually won the 2020 election
if you think that there is anything that
would get him to admit i just genuinely
lost to biden
i don't know what it would be
but let me know what you think could get
him to admit that
one of our sponsors is magic spoon the
only breakfast cereal that tastes
exactly like your favorite sugary
childhood cereals but with zero sugar
only four net carbs and 14 grams of
protein so if you're just generally
trying to keep your sugar intake
relatively low like me or if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto you
can enjoy the sweet nostalgic snack
without the sugar in flavors like cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter cookies and
cream maple waffle blueberry cinnamon
they've just added honey nut to their
permanent collection i love magic spoon
our whole team does and they've been
supporting the show for years how about
this if you try magic spoon and you
don't think it's amazing like we do
they'll give you your money back because
magic spoon stands behind their product
because it's that good you really can't
tell it apart from the classic cereals
build your own custom variety pack
you'll get five dollars off when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is in the description